I'm so bad with money I'm like the worst
person to give advice where's all your
money allocated percentage-wise uh I'd
say like 50 crypto
I made 20. bought the chain made another
20. bought a cat that was bad 20 000 I
have two why because you have 40 000 in
cats the hype house is a net negative
really absolutely it has lost me so much
money some of tick tock's biggest stars
are now roommates it's a Content house
it'd be like living in a movie set
I lost hundreds of thousands of dollars
on that house five legal disputes in
three years it has lost me so much money
so you probably heard of Charlie and
Dixie dimelio Addison Ray and all the
other millionaire Tick Tock stars that
have recently transformed into
mainstream celebrities however behind
all of that attention is someone you
might not have heard of and that would
be Thomas Petro here's his unbelievable
story and how anyone could make millions
of dollars online as soon as you
subscribe if you haven't done that
already well thank you so much for
coming on thanks for having me this is
cool because I remember just like the
come up of like hearing about the hype
house everything during covid just like
spiked through the roof of like Tick
Tock social media you were in it a whole
bunch and I hear that you were an
entrepreneur starting from the age of
like 11 or 12. yeah yeah so I've been
didn't have the greatest upbringing
sorry
um but I always had I feel like I'm sure
that as entrepreneurs yourselves you
know that it's like a disease that you
can't shake like I was just that kid in
Middle School who would just like order
stuff on Alibaba and flip it and sell it
and like anything I could do I sat out
in front of um I used the first way I
made money was like I would work for my
grandparents on the weekend because we
did a farmer's market so I'd be in the
factory jarring olives I'd be like
knee-deep and honey like jarring it for
us on the weekends and I would make like
thirty dollars working for 12 hours for
my grandfather like it was like terrible
terrible wages but I didn't know that
when you're 12 and you're working in a
factory like you don't really know that
but I'm like forever grateful because he
he taught me like hard work and real
world honey honey all of Scarlets where
are you getting the honey do you
remember the honey from Grace you ever
used to like there's a honey sticks of
farmers I love that I love those yeah
but we did we did uh garlic which would
have like red bell pepper flakes like
all the stuff my grandfather would help
us make it but he was from Greece so
he's an immigrant and he came over here
and just like they started doing produce
at the farmers markets and eventually he
started this thing called petrifoods
which is our last name and it it's not
around anymore but when I was a kid it
was the way I first started getting into
working and making money and then I
would save up for weeks and I would go
to footlockers and I would stay up until
six in the morning before school and I
would be like camping outside of
Footlocker did you guys know that people
used to do that for sneakers so when
there would be sneaker drops like before
goat and all these reseller apps you
would go and wait in line so I'd be like
a 13 year old kid in line with all these
30 year old dudes camping out yeah 6 a.m
you'd sleep at the store and you'd wait
for it to open first so you could get
all dangerous I mean I'm sure it was but
like I was just hustling so I would wait
but my parents thinking of that well 13
years shouldn't you be like in schools
yeah yeah I will well I had a
interesting upbringing um but my mom and
dad separated Young
they both made their mistakes I don't
really talk about their life story I
just try to talk about their impact on
me because I just feel like everyone's
story is their own and when you have a
rough upbringing it's not your place to
tell your parents story like that's why
I stick by that given that I was a lot
closer to my grandparents and like I
went back and forth I lived in like 14
different places before I graduated high
school so like I was I was very very
independent at a very young age so I
started learning how money worked and
how to buy food and groceries and all
that type of stuff like my mom always
had a roof over my head which I'm
forever grateful for but there was a lot
of times where I was alone so I just had
to like make it work regardless so they
they weren't very Hands-On so like I got
myself through school got myself like
everything I did was on my own so like
that's that's just like yeah it was it
was rough but I try not to talk about
the bad parts because I don't want my
parents to sound bad I love them I know
they tried their best but when they
separate when you're four and then your
mom my mom had my brother at I believe
19 or no my sister at 19 then my brother
at 21 and then me like 24. so by the
time they separated she was still not
even like 30 yet like I remember my
mom's 30th birthday it's like she
I had to grow up so quick with kids so
young but then when she was older she
wanted to like live her life and same
with my dad then he got remarried and
just like life was all over the place
but um I became very focused on just
how can I get to where I want to be so
like every day I went to school even
days where I had to get myself to school
it through I used to make Uber accounts
to get myself to school with my brother
and like when you could remake an email
and get a free account and all that
stuff but anything to get education so I
could get the hell out of there so that
was like my goal how did you inspire
yourself to like care so much because I
know so many people if they grow up in a
household similar to that they can be
become resentful they could become like
pessimistic they could just want to like
squander their time playing video games
and like not doing anything why did you
see the Silver Lining what made you
different I don't I don't I think that
it's
it's honestly crowd and I was very I was
a very big loner in school so like I
didn't hang out with anybody I didn't
have birthday parties I didn't have any
like I just stuck to myself and I was
just like if I can get myself through
this to 18 I'm gonna go off to college
and I'm Gonna Be Rich like that was my
life I was like I'm gonna get to school
I picked engineer to go to school for
because I was like engineers make the
most money so I was like that's what I'm
gonna do I dropped out after a month but
that's okay made it there
um but I was just like I want to get
good grades I want to be proud of myself
like I did it all for myself not for
anyone else and I think that's what
I feel like a lot of kids that end up
going down the wrong path it's like they
might have
other people in their life being like
you need to go to school you need to do
this that's the only way to live and
then with their upbringing they're like
well drugs sound great well this is a
lot easier well I'm gonna start doing
this and I I thankfully just kind of I
just kind of had a good head on my
shoulders from a very young I think you
were just born that way like you you
just always had a natural apprehension
towards like those drugs and other ways
of life I never I didn't drink till I
was 21 I never have smoked I've never
done any drugs like I've smoked
cigarettes a couple times but like I've
never smoked weed I've never done
anything why cigarettes it's going to be
an odd like no to alcohol but that
cigarette over here I smoked a couple
cigarettes when I was young in that
environment and stuff like that but I
was just a very like
I didn't like feeling out of my own body
sure yeah so like I had a really really
dramatic instance in high school where I
had my hand cut in half and you can kind
of see like you can see the scars all
throughout my finger so I like lost
feeling in most of this hand what
happened got sucked into a shop back in
in shop class so you know like the
you know how machines have little like
nose or little nozzles that can soak up
all the sawdust yeah like suck it all up
the central unit for that was being
taken apart and these kids turned it on
and my hand was on the table next to it
so it got sucked in because it's like a
really strong industrial vacuum so just
Blended my fingers up that was bad
what hat like what was their reaction
when freaked everyone freaked out
in a complete accident like I never sued
the school everyone told me to I never
sued anybody I was just like I'm gonna
play it
Good Karma but the surgery ended up
being like 160 times for that thank God
my dad works for the hospital he's a
respiratory therapist so he had
insurance so I just covered all of it
like for for me 160
000 hand surgery it was bad though like
I had like seven arteries burst in my
hand I had all the ligaments cut in half
the bones were broken I had pins all
throughout my hand to fix it all it was
still like you have sensation and
everything now yeah it's it's back-ish
but this is eczema that's why it looks
like that but I like like this like
light touch I can't feel but the pinky
and the thumb I can so when I grab
something it's like part of the
sensation is not there so it's but it
but thank God I was 17 when it happened
so I had time for it to heal but the
reason I brought that up was because as
I remember getting on morphine when
right when they got there because it was
just crazy incidents and then they gave
me Oxycodone to take home and when I got
home that night like excruciating pain
just had a 12 hour like I had to wait to
eat and then I had surgery was stuck in
the hospital finally get home and it's
like hurting really bad obviously the
next day because I have like metal rods
through my hand and I took the Oxycontin
and I flushed them down the toilet like
30 minutes later like I felt it take
over my body like in a way of I don't
know how people choose to do that like I
obviously I feel bad for anyone out
there who's addicted to opioids but it's
like oh my God I could never do that it
like took me out of my own body and I
was like I don't like this at all now
I'm curious when your hand went through
that thing yeah what did it feel like
honestly it didn't really hurt until the
paramedics got there it then it started
like hitting in like I so I got sucked
in
it was in a Flash and like what's crazy
is somehow the machine these things
don't have like safety precautions on
them because it's a unit for a central
system like it's like an AC unit doesn't
have if you stick your hand in it it's
not going to stop it's not made for that
where a saw has heat sensors and all
those things but somehow the machine
stopped when my hand went in there it
should have just like kept going which
would have been god-awful but thank
goodness it's just like right when my
hand hit it stopped went to the bathroom
and I put my hand under the sink to like
wash it off to see how bad because I
knew it hurt but I was like holding it
and I was like is it bleeding and
everything oh like score like everywhere
like a horror scene yeah like oh my yeah
and you went to the bathroom just by
yourself yeah I just went to the
bathroom to be like what happened what
am I gonna do and I put my hand on the
sink and I saw all my fingers like
wiggle sideways when I put water on it
yeah it was awful and I I was like oh
and I I was losing so much blood
um I was kind of freaking out and then I
passed out on the floor because I was
just like but in before I did I wrapped
each finger in like the you know those
brown paper towels like the ones at
every school I like wrapped as many as I
could and I was held it and I fell
asleep and then 30 minutes later the
paramedics got there like shot me up
with morphine unpeeled it as it like
opened up all of that and they were like
thank God you wrapped it because you
would have most likely lost your fingers
because you kept that pressure on the
entire time and like thank goodness it
didn't go through completely so it's
just like they just have to fix the
bones and then do a whole surgery it was
rough someone followed you into the
bathroom afterwards my yeah my teacher
came in kind of like panicking at the
time
yeah they called they called that one
immediately
um but yeah it was it sucked a lot of
people that I saw that were older that
had never drank had never smoked that
never done any of that stuff they kind
of had a stick up there like they were
very like
I'm better than you because I don't do
those things so when I turned 21 I was
like I'm gonna get drunk like what what
I can't let this control me this fear of
becoming an alcoholic and not being a
good dad one day or being a good parent
like I was like I'm not gonna let that
affect my life to the point where I'm
never gonna do anything so I drank a
couple times here and there after that
but I was just like I don't want I don't
want to drugs and like those things that
control me and how was it your first
time drinking it was fun it was fun I
was with good people having a good time
so like I think that there's a lot of
problems with alcohol in this country
but that's just my personal opinion I
think people get very addicted to it and
it ruins lives it makes people violent I
agree it's totally destigmatized like
there's no real like oh my God this guy
drinks but there can be with like
cigarettes and weed and other stuff like
that but alcohol could be just as if not
more destructive oh 100 I think I I
don't I might be wrong here but I'm
pretty sure there was a clip that I saw
of Joe Rogan talking with someone about
this or maybe uh Jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson was it yeah we're saying how
it's the only drug that inherently makes
people violent yeah no one's gonna go
rob a bank when they're high like it's
just like but weed has such a stigma and
keep in mind I don't smoke I don't I
don't smoke weed I never have but it's
just like I've been around people who
spoke that are chill and like lay down
watch a movie relax and then I've seen
people with alcohol in their system try
to beat the out of whoever they see
and you're just like which one of these
is truly mentioned something about
people being killed or murdered 50 of
all murders and 50 of all people who
murder are drunk drunk is that crazy and
you're like interesting but it's
interesting I always thought like if
you're gonna pick between one of the two
casually I think it's better probably to
be a casual drinker than it is casual
like a weed smoker but if you're
choosing like something that you're
doing on the daily like whether that be
like you know to wake up or like to go
to bed or something like that I think
it's way better to like smoke weed like
yeah yeah like on a daily basis yeah
than it is to be drinking every day I
think yeah like a glass of wine at
dinner is exactly or a beer like with
your dinner is totally fine also I think
with weed a lot of people forget and
they don't they don't want to
acknowledge the fact of when you're
young it has a lot harsher of an effect
like you can lose IQ points over time
from smoking so much weed when you're 13
to 18. it's like the kids don't really
talk about that because they just want
to like get high and have fun but it's
like there are cognitive things that
happen from smoking too much at a young
age so it's like wait till you're older
like if you're gonna experiment with
that stuff but it's just never been my
thing I've always just been very like I
wanna
get to work make as much money as
possible provide a good life for my kids
when I have them and all that stuff so
I've just never seen the point in any of
that but first before we go into that we
want to say a huge thank you to our
sponsor stream yard so we just bought
three new Sony fx3 cameras I don't know
if you guys can tell like a difference
in the quality but it's extremely
expensive this entire set I don't even
want to think about how much it costs
thankfully though if you want to get
started producing high quality content
you don't have to do it with spending a
lot of money in the very beginning we
spent nothing and stream yard is one of
the perfect ways that you could get
started streamyard is a live streaming
software that lets you create high
quality content with just the click of a
button all you need is a camera and an
internet connection to start streaming
right from your browser another thing
about stream yard is they actually offer
multi-streaming which basically means
that you can stream on every single
platform all at the same time which is
amazing because it basically increases
your reach at the cost of nothing
honestly they're one of the best ways
that you could begin creating content
without spending any money whatsoever
and just getting started today for free
because if you don't start you're never
gonna do it you keep putting it off you
may may as well begin today so again
check out streamyard down below in the
description they've been a fantastic
sponsor of ours and we've used their
product for years we'd be talking about
them regardless of whether or not they
sponsored a video because they're that
good so enjoy and now let's get back to
the video so why'd you drop out of
college I started YouTube when I was
16 made a couple Vlogs here and there
Casey neistat at the time was like the
biggest YouTuber and I looked up to him
and what he did and I was like I'm gonna
start daily vlogging so I was 17 and it
was like December 31st 2016 like going
to 2017 was the first daily Vlog I
posted and I kept up with it for they
started around the same time really yep
and I started for well I did it for
three years in like two months every
single day I uploaded and so during that
time I like was getting all my college
acceptance they're all still up no no I
private at all why come on man dude
that's the type of stuff that's like
that proves like Oh I'm a grinder like I
work hard
well I had a I had a previous
relationship that I was in through all
of high school and like she was in a lot
of that content and I don't think you
just blur her out no I just like I just
felt like that was a different chapter
of my life that I didn't really want
people going back to and watching like
me at 16 all the way to I kind of did it
for myself like I just wanted to prove
that I could work hard enough to get
that done I thought it was going to end
up blowing up because daily vlogging was
the thing at the time but I never it
never like made it and I didn't look
back at the content like wow every Vlog
was entertaining it was like most of it
was very boring I was just trying to do
something sure so it was just hard work
but that was the example of like hard
work versus smart work like it didn't it
helped me obviously in the big picture
but like I didn't make any money doing
it I didn't like get success doing it
but what it did is help give me
opportunity throughout time because I
got respect from other people who were
successful YouTubers
um but I was documenting applying to
colleges and I documented when I got in
I got into NYU it was the I applied to
17 schools I had a 4.1 or 4.2 GPA had a
great ACT score great SAT score and I
only got into one out of 17 schools I
applied to and it was my dream school
which was NYU and so I got up moved to
New York I started the summer program
early I was just like ready to get out
of San Diego and I left and after two
weeks I knew it wasn't for me everyone
told me that College is going to be the
experience those gonna be very different
like from high school that everything
was going to be more fun and the
learning was going to be more Hands-On
but and I got there and I was just like
hand another textbook and I was just
like I this isn't helping my life like
personally like I'm all for college if
it's what you want to do and if you have
if you want to be an engineer if you
want to be a lawyer if you want to be a
doctor go to school for me I was just
like I didn't even know what it meant to
be an entrepreneur because I was 17 in
college but it was like that's what I
wanted to do I just wanted to go start
something new so I thought of engineer
they make good money and they're
creative like that was my first thought
and that's not really what you get in
engineering school like you're doing a
lot of math and I was just like look I
love math and this is great but I'm not
going to graduate from college in four
years with 240 000 in debt and then work
my way off to hopefully pay off my loans
by the time I'm 40 doing a job that I
don't even know if I'm gonna like yet so
I was just like I'm out I'm moving to La
so that's what I did so you moved to LA
and did your YouTube channel at the time
have any traction no no traction how do
you know how do you financially move to
Los Angeles my cousin lived in La so he
went to UCLA and so I moved back to San
Diego for like a month and then I moved
to LA and I just packed up a bag
everything I brought to New York I just
brought with me to La and I stayed on
his couch in his apartment and it was a
three-bedroom apartment and there was
already three guys living in it and I
just like lived in a couch in the living
room and paid a couple hundred dollars
in rent and then I was just like well I
got to figure out what I'm gonna do so I
started doing Postmates and doordash and
all that stuff on top of daily vlogging
every single day so I was just like this
is I'm gonna do it I'm gonna make the
American dream happen like every kid
wanted to be a YouTuber at that time and
so I just kept grinding at it day in and
day out and I lived there for
two and a half years worth almost three
years before it even took off and so I
by the time about a year and a half into
it I met Jake Paul at a camera shop and
this was right when he started vlogging
so he was just this was before his major
blow up and I remembered him from Vine
and like I just went up and shot my shot
and talked to him and he ended up
following me on Twitter and then he
invited me over to the house until that
was the team 10 house at the time and
then I kind of we just started hitting
it off and we were on and off friends he
was a really cool dude to me what do you
say to Jake Paul when you see him at a
camera shop like how do you stand out at
that point I actually up and I
said uh Logan no and now I do and he was
like it's Jake and I felt so bad but I
had seen them all vine from like years
before and they were you know he was
crushing it but I yeah that was the
first thing I said like an idiot but he
was really cool and I have nothing but
good things to say about him he was like
a good Mentor for me at that time but
how do you get like what do you say to
get him to follow you on Twitter like
how do you recover from that so I had
taken my friend to the camera shop
sami's camera
um he's a videographer and he needed I
forgot what he needed a new lens or
something for a shoot and his car was
broken down so he asked me to take him
and then I see Jake Paul in the lobby
and I was like like in the center room
yeah and I was like man congrats on like
everything you've done like seeing you
on Vine and he was like oh what are you
doing here and I was like well I took my
roommate here but I'm a daily vlogger
and he was like oh no way I'm on day 50.
he was like what have you got you and I
was like oh my day like 530.
and he was like what so it paid off yeah
yeah he was just like why are you like
how many Subs do you have I was like
like 10 000. he was like shut the
up like no way this kid is working for a
year and a half every day with nothing
and so he invited me over and like a
couple videos blew up but I I never
passed like I think I had like 70 000
subscribers or something like that at
that time
um but he definitely helped and he was
in a lot of content with me and he was
super cool and I would sit down with him
and like we'd talk about what Vlog he
was gonna film and he was a really cool
dude yeah um but I would try to give
like creative ideas if I had any and he
would help me in my content we were just
friends and he was really cool I was
never in team 10 a lot of people thought
I was but I was just kind of like in and
around and I saw the success that he had
made through creating a Content house
and I just thought it was a great
concept like he took all these viners
put them together
it seems so simple in theory but then I
saw the complications that came with
that he did more of a business structure
like I I know that he like signed people
and helped blow them up and got a
percentage and all that and so I just
kind of adopted that mentality when I
started hype house I was like this
clearly works like if you can take a
bunch of people that are blowing up on
social media and put them in one Central
space it is going to work without a
doubt like you you could do it any day
anytime anyone could do it in every
Community right now you could take the
gym Community take 10 of those guys put
them in a house together you're going to
have the most entertaining content ever
it's if the people can continue that for
a long period That's the challenge but I
was like I know it'll work and then
later it was it ended up being like a
year and a half later I don't think team
10 was a thing anymore
um and it was 2019 Tick Tock had
purchased musically and I saw these tick
talkers blowing up and I was like people
are really overlooking this app like I
was like I know I did yeah most people
did my cousin kept telling me like
you've got to get on this app like I'm
telling you like at that time like I was
21 or 20 and he was just like you got
that look still you look yeah like just
get on there and do the trends and I was
like I don't want to do the trends like
I want to be a YouTuber like Casey
neistat and like these people I want to
be looked at or respected
I ended up downloading it and I was like
whatever and then I ended up messaging a
couple people and I was like this this
would be such a good idea if we all
moved in together and that's kind of
like how the idea of it started Brewing
but I had had it since team 10 I was
like I want to create a haunted house I
like just wanted to live with a bunch of
my friends and make cool content all
that that was a dream I had since I met
Jake because I just saw the environment
was so good yeah and what were you doing
in the meantime to sustain yourself
Postmates that was what you were doing
that was all I did but I mean it worked
like I knew people that were at this
time in 2019 like I knew so many people
that had office jobs that were making
three grand a month 3 600 to 4 grand a
month and I was making like four to five
doing Postmates eight hours a day like I
was like am I really good money yeah it
was good and I was just like am I crazy
or like I'm making more than you are and
I don't want to sit in a cubicle all day
like I get to go on my phone and like
call whoever I want while I'm driving
around La like yeah it sucked but it was
like not bad money for for being at no
he did for great years years like 2002
years and when did you stop the data
vlogging I stopped it in right before
hype house so 20 2019 like uh end of
2019 I would say so what did you see in
Tick Tock I overlooked it when I first I
downloaded it 2019 early 2019 and I was
just like young girls lip syncing and
dancing and I'm like what this is not an
app that like I could create content for
I think what it was is that I saw
musically musically was like a little
blip that everyone kind of like
overlooked but those creators on
musically got so so big so fast but they
got no or like little mainstream
recognition like I don't know if you
remember all the musically people all
the musers but I'm sure you remember a
lot of the tick talkers yeah so it's
like I'm sure that most people out there
if you have a phone and like watch up
you know who like Charlie and Dixie and
Addison and these big names or hype
house like you know who they are from
Tick Tock but if you look at musically
they never really scratched that surface
to like real celebrity like and I know
that people get upset with that but like
there's a lot of the tick tock workers
that made it to that threshold even if
they aren't there now like they were
celebrities and some are still there
like Charlie and Dixie in them like
they're still celebrities I know that
they're not as famous as like the
Kardashians or whatever maybe but
they're very successful and people
recognize them as that Tick Tock I saw
as the after they purchased it I was
like more I just had a feeling more
people were gonna get on it like I I
felt like more people were gonna pay
attention and so once I met a couple
other people like on Tick Tock and met
Chase and Alex and all these people I
was like if we all get together and we
all move into the same house it'll
probably do very well and like we knew
we didn't know we were gonna make a page
for it and all that like we knew we were
gonna have a Content house and call it
something but I we didn't have like a
set plan and there was no business model
there was no nothing I was just like
let's just all moving together so I'll
pay rent like trust me this is gonna
work and they were all down and so we
all moved in together I got this house
in like two weeks we got a rental house
like put the deposit down and then we
ended up it just it ended up taking off
so quickly once we made that page the
hype house like once we were like okay
this is what we're gonna do we posted on
just went viral like overnight it was my
understanding you found a lot of these
people like really really really early
yeah when did you find Charlie demilia
well I didn't really find her like I met
her through Chase and Chase was like we
kind of just
mingled with them at we were at an
Airbnb before hype house and we're just
all hanging out and we're like had this
idea of moving in with our friends and
all that and that's when we first met
them and they were just they were just
really cool people like there was no
like Talent scouting like oh that's not
how it was in the beginning it was like
oh these people are my friends and they
do the same thing so why don't we all
get together and work together that was
kind of the concept behind it yeah and
how were you with them though were you
popping off on Tick Tock at the time no
I was more of hey I've seen all the
things that have gone wrong with
management and all this stuff through
musically people that I knew through
YouTubers that I knew
people were very very taken advantage of
out in La like especially by managers
and agents and I'm sure you guys know
that but a lot of people are very very
bad towards these people and I was just
like hey I know the rates I know all
this stuff and I was like I don't want
to manage you I'm not going to take any
of your money I don't want to be an
agent to you but I will help you reply
to these emails help you close these
deals just for you like I'm not making
anything off of it but I don't want to
see you get robbed by your management
and it's like I knew so many people even
through hype house that had bad agents
bad managers all that stuff and so I was
just kind of like hey I have this idea
for the house and let's do this and
let's all get together make it happen
and I'll advise with all these things
that I had learned over the years but
how did you even get your foot in the
door if you weren't popular well I had a
following from so enough to be able to
DM yeah I had like 80 000 on Instagram
and like 100 000 on YouTube so it wasn't
like big but these tick tockers at the
time like only had a couple hundred
thousand followers on Instagram like
they were popping but not like what
happened in 2019 to 2020 then maybe like
everyone catapulted
um but that's kind of how it started was
just mostly through networking and I'd
also been doing photography videography
so I'd linked up with a couple people to
shoot for them and stuff like that so
what was the initial goal of the high
pass what was your adjustments hey let's
all move in together let's all make
content together let's all help each
other out that was the whole concept
behind it
and I was like I saw what hadn't worked
for team 10 in the past which was I
figured
hey if we don't sign anyone if we don't
take any money from anybody no contracts
you can leave whenever you want
it'll be a lot more genuine and then if
people end up leaving we'll just have a
revolving door of talent so that's kind
of like the concept was was just hey
let's make a group account and let's all
post on it and that first place you got
was a super nice spot or or was it was
it here in L.A it was in Encino and it
was it was a good house there it had
some issues but we weren't really it
wasn't like a fancy place but it was the
big like entryway was very noticeable
and so when we first moved in there we
started having a bunch of people over
that at the time like everyone was
starting to move to LA for tick tock
because all these tick tockers were
blowing up and they were making money
and they were like well we got to move
to LA and do this that was just kind of
part of it so they all came over to our
house and we would all film in the same
bathroom and then at that time tick
tock's algorithm was very location based
so if you set your phone up in our
bathroom it got millions of views like
it was without a question yeah it wasn't
because Tick Tock then was all based on
faces and location like you could tell
the algorithm work that way so if you if
anyone had come to our house we had
people come that had 100 followers that
would put their phone up and that video
went viral every time so we were just
like clearly when this background of
this bathroom hits the 4u page it go it
does well so everyone wanted to come
over because all the content was being
seen by everyone else in the space and
that's kind of like how it started that
was before hype house even existed it
was just I think I remember the bathroom
it's called The Tick Tock bathroom
that's what people said good lighting
though right good lighting and like all
of us were just filming in the same spot
so that's kind of how it all just like
started how did you afford that place if
there was so many of us living there oh
it was not what was the rent how many
people were there so it was room size
but the average room had like two people
in it and it was like 1500 per room
because it was like seven bedrooms so it
was a big house but it was how do you
even convince the landlord at that point
to like move in that many people that's
a good question
um I don't even know how it happened it
happened so fast
I think well we sat down with the
landlord and we explained what we've
explained what we were going to do but
we didn't think it was going to blow up
like the way it did like we were all of
us were small-ish and making enough
money to afford the rent between all of
us but it wasn't like we we didn't
expect it to go so big and then have
like the New York Times come shoot it
and like all this like we just didn't
expect that we just thought we were
going to be friends living together
um but I remember we talked to Atlanta
we told me we were gonna do but we told
him like we're not gonna damage the
house we're not gonna do anything crazy
all that type of stuff and he he just
rented it to us we got lucky
and did you end up damaging the house or
was it like there was definitely a
couple things that were broken but the
security deposit was like 20 grand and
he ended up taking that when we left but
there was a whole situation with that
um but we left at least early remember
the team 10 house wasn't that trash yeah
apparently they they did a lot but I
thought that they fixed most of it I
don't know I'm sure that they had to pay
some damages for that it was crazy I
drove by the uh that house yeah I
remember like so many people always just
hanging out in front of it the tree was
just vandalized oh I'm sure people would
come up with knives and just draw into
the tree it's crazy so our second house
was the worst like the first house had a
gate and then it was up a driveway yeah
so even when we started popping like it
started blowing up and all that we would
have like a couple people drive up and
like find their way in through the code
and like a couple people would like walk
up the driveway or like push the gate
apart and get up there but it was
trespassing so it was like a lot less
people are gonna do that than when
you're on the street at the second house
we're on the street and there was at
least 40 50 people there every single
day which house was that on Hollywood
yeah
that house was insane so what would you
do that was the former phase house right
yeah yeah oh it was that house yeah it's
a huge one the glass yeah so yeah
basically what happened is six months
into high pass or even less I'd say
three to four months in a hype house
people were growing rapidly everyone was
doing really well everything was great
covet hits
well covet had been there but like
covered lockdown hits
so everyone had to go home so most the
people that were in the house like we
had the people who lived there but the
people that were a part of it that
didn't live in the house they all had to
go home like we weren't allowed to you
couldn't hang out with people obviously
it was a health risk like you couldn't
go a block away and go hang out with
your friends like it was very very
frowned up like do not be around anyone
if you don't have to so in you guys had
rules in the hype House of like yo
you're not going out and like no no it
wasn't really rules we all just kind of
came together and we're like hey it's
locked down like we shouldn't go
anywhere we shouldn't have anyone over
so that's going to affect people but I'm
talking about the people that were
traveling that lived in other states
like they went home they were they were
like we're not staying in LA and like
getting a hotel or an Airbnb to be
locked up and like I'm just going to go
home so at that time I was like whoa
it's either just like shut it down after
three or four months or I gotta figure
something out and so we were like okay
well if we move to a bigger house even
though it's during covet if we live with
25 people people can't really say like
that because the whole you're like you
have to social distance and we were like
well what if we all live in the exact
same house then it's like if you live
with your family no one cares if you
live with your friends no one cares if
you had a roommate like that wasn't
really a big deal so we ended up getting
the next house and we lived with
think 22 people or 20 people it was
crazy and so that was when I was like
I'm gonna add more people different
people and just see if it works like if
I add a bunch of new people and everyone
hates it like whatever it is what it is
but that's when we blow up the most was
at that second house after like adding
eight other tick talkers from other like
we had so many people a part of it it
just kept going and going and going and
then all the attention kept getting put
on us so I was like well we're
entertaining people during covid you
broke that lease early of that first
place yeah how do you make that
Financial jump between that first place
and that's my place how much was that
like 50 Grand a month yeah I can't go
into too much detail on that house
um just because there's a pending
situation with it that I can't really
talk about but what I can say
is that I lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars on that
house
hundreds that I have spent on that place
the place was 50 000 a month almost it
was like 45 000 a month and I put a 90
000 security deposit that that's gone
yeah then I paid over a hundred thousand
dollars after that and the entire rent
during that time
so like we I think we split it for the
first few months and then for the last
couple months I paid it how they were
paying 45 000 a month rent we're making
good money like my my YouTube videos
were doing
three to five million per post three
times a week like they were we were
crushing and like brand deals were
flowing in for everybody everyone was
making good money because that was that
we were all so big at that time
everything every post got millions of
views no matter what we did so it wasn't
even bothering you to be fronting that
45 no no it was bothering me it was just
um it was just hey we all signed a lease
so like we gotta live up to it and then
that situation got even worse like
yeah both places we broke early the
first place
it's not worth getting into but there
was a couple things wrong with the
actual house which is why we left and
then it was getting to a safety hazard
with people coming in and breaking in so
that's why we left the first one so we
had a girl break in and like vandalize
the place even after after we moved out
because that was when we started like
actually growing significantly and then
the second house just like that was a
show but yeah that that place has lost
me a ton of money big big regret it also
made you a lot of money it did and it
made everyone else a lot of money being
in and around that time but I was so
glad that I bought my next house because
I was just like I don't want to be
sued by another landlord or deal with
anything like that so I was like I'll
never rent a place ever again in my life
when you're talking about a video
getting like three to five million views
what's the ad revenue or something like
that if my CPM wasn't great at first
because I was doing five minute videos
eventually I worked it up to eight
minutes and so I could do the mid-rolls
during it but it was doing good I would
say like each post like 20 grand no yeah
it got up there and they were doing yeah
they were doing whoa yeah so everyone
and that was your own personal channel
that was my personal Channel High Pass
we didn't post on and it was just too
complicated with like members coming in
members coming out I didn't want the
drama associated with it so we just kind
of like took a break from it and just
stuck to Tick Tock but yeah no it was
good good money and I was just grinding
that all day I was doing YouTube every
second I was awake and it's funny
because so many people thought they were
like dude this guy's making Bank off of
all these people in hype house I was
like actually I don't sign anyone no
one's made me a dollar off of this thing
why not because that they were equally a
part of it as much as I was and they
were putting Mo in the beginning I think
everyone was putting equal like effort
into this thing like we were all
passionate about everyone was happy it
wasn't like a I'm making hype house to
make money like it was like this is
supposed to be a collective thing that
everyone's a part of and so I was just
like I'm not taking a percentage of
anyone it just felt wrong I still don't
like the concept of it I don't like when
people do it now it's like to me I I get
it in some situations like when rappers
if Drake signs you you're gonna make a
ton of money so it's like it makes
sense for him to like co-sign an artist
tick talkers YouTubers it's just like so
many people have tried it it never works
out well so I was just like that's not
what I want to do like I want to help
these people as much as I can I want to
give them an environment to thrive and
work off of each other and all that and
I don't mind but I'm gonna work on my
own thing too and so that was my benefit
and it was like this whole thing helped
my career immensely I'm like I'm forever
grateful for everyone who has been a
part of it who's a part of it currently
like they these people have helped
change my life and I've hoped that I've
helped change theirs but I was just like
I don't I don't want to get into the
management business they like that that
just wasn't what I wanted to do I wanted
to be a Creator yeah and so I was
grinding on YouTube every day but I
didn't make any money through high pass
hype house has lost me so much money
like it is just yeah it oh there has to
be a net positive though no no no hype
house is a net negative really
absolutely why
absolutely it's like a resounding map
yeah no no absolutely it has lost me so
much money I have been through five
legal disputes in three years where I
did nothing wrong and most of them have
just been dealt with immediately but
like no like I've been it has caused me
a lot more harm than good outside of the
like first year like it no yeah if
cheese
I'm proud that I have helped a lot of
people in my eyes and like I'm just glad
that we made such a big impact in that
time but yeah no and I'm grateful for
the experience and grateful for
everything because I think everything's
a Learning lesson in life but no yeah
net hype house no not negative
I feel like that's life though because
not every business you create right it's
gonna be profitable what a lesson to get
out of the way early though yeah yeah
it's insane yeah no lawsuits are not fun
I wish that I could share details on
them but you can't as I'm sure many
people out there know it's just not it's
also not the right thing to do in those
situations like you don't go out and
spill all the details of who sued for
what and this and that but like these
lawsuits by the way were not with like
people in the house like these are like
things from outside like people I've
never met things that I like just like
people very frivolous lawsuits that I've
gotten dealt with but yeah it's been a
bunch of shows but yeah that's part
of running a business that's what that's
what all my attorneys always say that
they say it's the cost of doing business
which I get but like the mental wear
down that those have had on me like I've
been suicidal multiple times the last
couple years and I don't mind talking
about it but like it destroyed my mental
health more than anything in what way
well when you're accused of something
yeah that you didn't do and you're
fighting it with full force and you know
that even when you win you still lose
because you spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars on legal bills you don't get
a dollar back even when you win and then
you just don't want to like spend your
life counter suing and suing people of
wrong you know that's just like not the
way I want to live my life but when
you're getting like pushed down
everything on you and I had my childhood
and like don't have close family in my
life and like very deal with a lot of
issues personally already like that
stuff just makes it like so much worse
and like money is money is great and I
am so so grateful for my position I'm so
grateful I would pick Rich over broke
any day and I've been both but money
doesn't fix your mental health and it
doesn't help you with relationships and
it doesn't help it actually makes a lot
of things worse and I'm sure that you
guys have dealt with that people coming
back in your life that want something or
people that you just meet you never know
what their true intentions are and it's
in La people view clout as a currency
even more than money which is very very
strange but like you don't even know
when anyone's being genuine to you half
the time and like I'm sure that you I
don't know if you guys have dealt with
that I haven't yeah I'm so cheap I
almost don't spend money though that's
that's the thing if people know what
they're getting into with me well but I
mean but also like Fame and stuff like
that alters people like I had people
text me from high school that I haven't
talked to in six years that are just
like could you send me some money for
this and I'm like what like I haven't
talked to you at all why the would
I send you money like I don't know how
much are they asking for just like hey
could you help me buy this I'm I'm down
bad I'm Dr I'm like addicted to this and
this and I'm like where is this my
problem like we aren't friends you're an
old person I knew in high school you
weren't even a friend in high school
like what I people are crazy and then
like family issues and all that stuff
it's like money complicates everything
but it also is a beautiful thing that
gives you Freedom so it's like you you
when some you lose some yeah but some of
my best best memories life or when I was
broke for sure like I think that's just
what people don't really understand
about money is like yes it's great and
it's so hard because I said the same
thing that I'm sure that people watching
this podcast are thinking which is if I
had this all my problems would go away
no you they wouldn't and by the time you
get to those problems those problems are
bigger than anything you've ever faced
so it's like for example if you have a
lawsuit that costs you 500 000 to get
through you will never ever ever get
that when you're broke because they're
not gonna get anything so no one's ever
gonna sue you no one's ever gonna do
that because you don't have anything to
lose so it's like when you're broke you
really only have up to go like outside
of your health like take care of your
health and all that but Financial wise
like that's all you really have to worry
about where once you have money it's
like people trying to bring you down you
got to maintain that lifestyle if you
bring that up there's a lot of
complications that come in with that and
the relationships with people you have
to make sure you're having the right
circle around you and good friends and
good family and all that gets a lot more
complicated once you reach success
whatever that means to you every time we
have this discussion on the podcast I
check the comments and everyone's like
of course it's just once again three
dudes talking about like how money
doesn't have like make you happy or
whatever but in the same way that you've
experienced like pure Bliss and
happiness and some of the best moments
in your life when you didn't have money
same thing for me like some of the
happiest parts of my life or when I was
in high school I had no money no job
couldn't get a job and I was running
cross-country just hanging out my people
you don't realize that's the good time
until you look back at it exactly so it
makes you realize hey now could be no
that was the good you know what I mean
who knows well and everything I hate
Nostalgia I'm a very I which sounds
weird but like I'm not a nostalgic
person at all I don't think back on a
time of like
the good old days I think you're always
living them and if you stop and look
around a little bit you'll realize that
everyone's gonna remember this year
everyone says like oh 2023 sucks but
then in 2026 they're gonna be like God I
missed 2023 and you're just like you
don't realize it but everyone's like oh
2019. the only posts I see now where
people like 2020 was the best year and
I'm like you were locked inside yeah was
it really the best year or are you just
being nostalgic because it's been three
years it's like it'll always go through
the 2020 was the best that's a trend
yeah it's when people are like 2020 it
was a rough year 2021 was a rough year
and they always reflect at the end of
the year I hate that Trend it makes no
sense to me but I also get for people
there are a lot of there is situations
where finances like your financial
situation could make a lot of your
problems go away which I totally
understand there's a lot of freedoms
that come with making money but honestly
like I think after maybe with inflation
now I I always used to say 10 000 a
month anything more than that is like
very it's just frivolous like you could
live a very good life with ten thousand
dollars a month now with inflation
that's probably if you live in LA
probably closer to 15 to 20.
um if you live anywhere else outside of
major cities 10 grand a month is still
like you could do pretty much you could
get a really cool car you could get a
nice house you could do a lot of things
with 10 grand a month but La it's things
are expensive here anything past like
I'd say 15 000 a month like life doesn't
really change the toys get bigger or
cooler but it doesn't really change your
life like the stress levels don't really
change unless you put them up to that
level then you gotta like you live in
the same spot as if you bring your bills
up to ten thousand a month then you're
gonna feel just like you did when you
made four grand a month like it's not
gonna change anything for you because
you're putting the same stress into it
that you would if you didn't have as
much money so what do you spend money on
cars like what
um I have seven cars I don't know why uh
but I love listening what was the first
first like nice car you bought I bought
Tanner Fox's old gt3s I still have it
yeah yeah but before that I bought a
Tesla Model 3. so I had a Mazda 3 all of
high school all three that's cars that
was Postmates then
um I got a model three and that was like
my first I'm so bad with money I'm like
the worst person to give advice I don't
you know I'm good with Investments and
like building up a portfolio and all
this type of stuff and I make smart
choices like I bought real estate during
covid when everyone said don't buy real
estate and now my house has gone up 40
in a couple years so it's like I make
good choices like that but I'm just very
like I was just a broke dumb kid with
money like I know that that people
understand you can be rich or be broke
like mentality wise like even if you
make a lot of money you can still be
broke because you're dumb so it's like
my first 20 grand I bought a chain I
bought I spent 17 000 out of my twenty
thousand I was my bank account on a
necklace why
it was a chain it was a yeah it was a
nice chain and I was so hyped on it but
I always wanted one so I bought it and I
had 20 grand my bank account I spent 17
on it how did that make you feel that
like once you break it you're like great
that way yeah three yeah I was just like
I'm gonna make more have to how did you
make that 20 grand uh was it like a
YouTube video that popped off no it's
just pre-youtube I think it was we had a
lot of sound promos back in the day so
like everyone else was very focused on
like I gotta keep my feet good with
Trends and I was like I gotta make as
much bread as possible during this time
because this stuff doesn't last forever
which is very true but I took everything
so it'd be like a sound promo day for
three five grand
and I was like
I'll do this every day and everyone's
like you can't do them every day like
your feed won't be as good I was like I
don't give a about my feed that's
150 Grand a month if I take a five
thousand dollar sound promo every day
like why would I not use this sound
promise just them saying user sound yeah
yeah or like or brand deals that came in
and all that stuff but I made 20 bought
the chain made another 20. bought a cat
a cat a cat that was a bad twenty
thousand dollars I have two why because
you have 40 000 in cats I think it was
like it was like 36. you're laughing
it's not funny why
because what type of cat is this uh
Savannah cat I have two of them they're
big they're like 20 pounds I always
wanted them uh aren't those the ones
don't they get kind of like aggressive
but but they're mine are like super
sweet and well trained um but yeah they
were I know people would be pissed
because I bought cats but um yeah I it
was just like do you ever see Archer no
the show all right well on Archer
there's an ocelot and it's a exotic
animal you can't own and I always wanted
one and this is the closest you could
get so I bought one and then he was
lonely so I bought another one but
um yeah so bad choices it's even what
about the Tesla what about the next 20
grand though Tesla okay and the next
time and that was just down and I was
like I gotta make this payment and then
once I paid off the Tesla I put it down
on the gt3rs
and then I just had to pay that off so
it's like I you I didn't come from like
no one was there advising me where to
put money no one was there like I feel
like I'm I was very financially similar
to a lot of like athletes that come into
money or a lot of boxers like you know
like any anyone that comes from nothing
and just like doesn't know what they're
doing it doesn't have guidance from
parents or anyone else around them so
it's like as that money just floated and
I was like I'll just burning through it
who cares and then you get hit with
taxes what about like cars well the cars
are a different business for me now but
I I just love cars like I after the gt3s
I got addicted I bought a bunch
um and now I have seven but I have a
gt3s I've Tanner's old one I have a BMW
M3 2023 that's like the daily good car I
have a wide body Uris I have uh 720s I
have a fa tributo I have a crap uh
Huracan performante and a 1967 Fastback
yeah so I got a lot of cars what a
collection yeah for trying to get a
variety like American European you know
every brand is much less yeah I if I had
a hundred million dollars I would have
like 40 billion dollars in cars that's a
good collection yeah yeah no I'm super
proud of my collection I like it was
just a way for me I'm not like the
average person that comes into money and
like is like okay well I got this much I
got to put this much here put this much
here put it aside get investment portals
I was just like oh I just got to keep
working and make more
and that was just my mindset has that
changed at all oh absolutely yeah of
course I yeah and I I learned to
diversify and put it into you know like
and actually invest my money smartly but
I it's the same thing we're also like I
don't know what's wrong with me I don't
like debt and I know that there's some
people that are like this and most
people are not like this and it's not
the smart way to be it's like fearing of
debt but like all my cars are paid off
like I don't do the loan thing like I
just don't like it it bothers me like
I'd get a loan and then I wait six
months and pay it off the next day so
that it would improve my credit but I
was just like I don't like
owing anyone and we have a mortgage
right yeah but you have to have a
mortgage I feel like yeah like most
people don't pay off their houses and
there's so much more you can do with
that money where that's like a lump sum
but like to me I don't know like what
instead of paying off a 300 000 car like
you put the 300 Grand into what like
real estate and buy another house and
doing about anybody that's more time
because there's also like after owning a
home the reason I haven't gotten to into
real estate outside of my personal house
is like it's so much work
it's like unless you know what you're
doing you have a really good team but
then also I don't know how people trust
people because I'm not a very trusting
person because I had a bad child that
had lost a lot of people blah blah Etc
like
I don't just trust someone to go run an
Airbnb for me just like well then I'm
going to want to be Hands-On but then
how much of that is going into it versus
how much is it rewarding me that's kind
of like that it's not worth your time no
but for some people it is and it's a
great business if that's what you're
solely focused on so I'm a very like All
or Nothing type of person so I'm like
I'm either gonna focus on this full-time
or I'm gonna not waste my time on it so
it's like that's where stock market
cryptocurrency all that stuff's fun to
me because I look at it like a game and
I can do it for my phone but I mean it's
kind of like gambling to be honest too
oh gosh what are you talking about your
portfolio where's all your money
allocated percentage-wise oh you're not
gonna like that answer uh I'd say like
50 crypto 50 stocks
Bank
stuff like that but that's it so if
you're taking your entire like no
everything what is it um 40 percent
invested I'd say like 25 in the house
the house has gone up a lot or 20 of the
house and then cars 20 Bank the rest so
it's like not not bad it's not like I'm
not like it's still terrible no but I
should have but it's also I buy good
cars so like most my cars have made me
money they've all profited like they
haven't lost me money you never sold a
car no I have I've sold a bunch no it
might be a time to start selling off oh
no yeah what other cars have you had
that you've funnied up the only cars
I've lost money on are my Teslas all
three Teslas I had lost my body huh
because they just hold terribly because
they make a new one all the time and
like why would you buy a used Tesla when
you go online and buy one in a week I'm
surprised you don't have a Tesla right
now I hate them
it wasn't my dream car I always wanted
supercars but like dream car in
like real like anyone can afford the
Tesla realistically and I bought that
model three I had it for a couple months
great Carr loved it but then like I got
I got a model X after that because I was
dailying Tanner's gt3rs in La which is
not a good idea it just doesn't not
practical in any way so I was like
I gotta get a normal car so I bought a
model X I had it for a week before I
sold it because I was like I can't do
this thing once they're like going
electric again I couldn't do it and then
I bought a Model S plaid
um last year
couldn't do it everyone got car sick in
the back they all felt like throwing up
because the regenerative braking build
quality is terrible once you get into
like higher end cars I feel like you
once you get in like a Tesla you're like
the core and the concept and the
technology is brilliant but the actual
build of them is terrible like door
frames are misaligned like all this
stuff and and I think so I bought the
model S i you let my cousin use it to go
to San Diego and the motors blew on him
on the highway as he was driving down so
I came by this car was a week old or two
weeks old that's crazy you left did
someone borrow a weak old plaid to drive
down to oh yeah he was my cousin I was
just like he needed to go home and I was
like you can use it and he took it and
it blew on him so he was like stranded
there we had to get him back to LA it
was a whole show and I bring it to
Tesla and I'm like just give me a new
one it's got like 50 miles on it they
had the car for like nine weeks fixing
it I was like this car is a week old
you're not even giving me a loner this
car is a week old like that makes no
sense like Porsche would never do that
how would they not give you a loaner I
don't know they did to me they they
upgraded me oh they did yeah well it's
also like I didn't need the car like I
have other cars like I didn't need it
but the fact they didn't even offer it
like I was like I'm not gonna go take a
loaner from someone who doesn't have the
option of another car yeah but the fact
they didn't even offer a loaner or just
like if it was me I guess it's not their
choice obviously but if it was me like I
would just give them a new car he bought
it with 50 miles on it like why wouldn't
you just get a new one delivered and
just take that one and go fix it like
the motor shouldn't be blowing up on
them would you get the Roadster or the
Cyber truck I I have the Cyber truck
pre-ordered I have since the day it
launched four years ago yeah
um but the Roadster maybe I'm gonna see
how people react to it because the thing
is I got on the plaid and I was like oh
my God this is the fastest car I've ever
been in and I've been in a lot of
supercars that are like crazy
performance and also they don't compare
to have you been in applied yeah there's
nothing there's nothing it's like a
roller coaster it's like a roll yeah it
like shoots you back yeah and it's great
but it still doesn't feel real like it
still feels like a ride more than a car
and I don't like how smooth they are
like I like I like feeling like I can
feel the road and with those cars like I
would look down on the highway and be
like holy I'm going fast like way
faster than I drive my other car so yeah
like
130 on the freeway and I was like this
thing doesn't feel real like this is
dangerous and I yeah that car I just I
don't think I could get the Roadster
unless it was unless it's really blows
me away which it could but how do you
top 1.8 seconds on a plaid like what are
you gonna do is it gonna go 0.7 probably
it's probably gonna be like 1.5 but I
feel like they're gonna have to put a
legal limit on that there's a speed in
which you'll pass out like yeah you do
it in like under a second I think people
lose I'm sure that the government will
come in and be like hey 1.5
that's it you can't like you can't have
a car that goes 0 to 16 a second like
someone could put that in front of a
house and press on it through the house
right right that's too fast like that
becomes like well I know cars are
already dangerous but like just being
able to like park there yeah and just
shoot through this house is like that
can't be there's no way they're gonna
let that happen and also what's the I
feel like that takes away all the fun in
it but I don't know what's the point
yeah what's the point going that quick
there's quick versus fast fast I
understand the speed of getting going up
and up and up and getting in a Bugatti
and going 200 miles per hour that's a
cool thing on a track or whatever but a
plaid is just like yeah dude I think the
new thing instead of zero to 60 is going
to be 60 to 120. yeah maybe I could see
that yeah I mean if they can keep the
zero to 120. dude in like four seconds I
could imagine 60 to 120 in two seconds
and imagine that yeah well they're super
cars that can do that that are like
quick yeah like because the if I'm on
the highway in the 720 and I'm at 60
it's quick like 60 to 150 quick really
but it's not zero you'll slide like I'll
slide if I'm in anything over or under
third gear in the Ferrari or the McLaren
I'll just slide out so what was your
process of buying a house
so from Hollywood to yeah so I bought it
with two of my friends at the time and
we each put in I believe I put in 700
000 or 600 and something thousand and
they put in four and between the two of
them yeah so we were all just like okay
we're going in on this house and then
once they ended up moving out later I
was like hey well do you want me to buy
you out or do you want to keep your
investment in the property and they
chose for me to buy them out so I just
paid them out instead of and now it's
just mine but and how do you do that you
just get an appraisal yeah was it at a
new appraisal no is that the original
but they just wanted cash back like as
quick as possible so I was like hey I'll
pay you out on that I have no problem
with that because at that time the
market was finicky but I was like I
believe that it's gonna go up so I'm
gonna hold my advice I would say well
you know it would be this but then
there's commissions and escrow charges
so uh we'll take this
if you really if you think about it
though it's like 150 if the market did
crash yeah like it's gone up
significantly for me but if it did crash
I would have been because five
percent on a house to real estate agents
plus anything I had to fix or anything
like that like I would have lost a lot
of money yeah but it happened to go up
so it's like I think real estate's
pretty safe overall long term but you
know that's just me but yeah I bought
the house we did seller financing for
the first year because none of us had
good Banks like we had a good bank
statements for a year and a half but
like who's gonna trust that for the next
five years
um so we sell our finance at a high rate
it was like six to seven percent I think
it was really high and then I refinanced
at the end of the year knocked it back
down once it was just me I refinanced
and then now I'm selling it you're
selling it right now yeah what's he
asking seven five
I think you're gonna get it yeah so is
it on the market right now yeah seven
five yeah
Jesus but it's 12 000 square feet yeah I
didn't know it was that yeah I didn't
know it was that expense that nice I
bought it for five
three years ago
and I know the jump seems crazy yeah it
seems crazy but I bought it during covid
when no one was buying because everyone
was scared everyone I knew was like in
2020 they were like I'm not buying
anything because it was still during
lockdown like still Master like everyone
was just like I'm not buying right now
in LA or in the LA region because
everything's gonna go down that was the
thought process so what's the goals in
the current like close future for you
you just want to sell this house what
about other business stuff that you want
to be doing content this house
I think I've just lived with so many
people in it and it's like nothing
towards any of the people like all love
and respect towards everyone but like
I've lived with so many roommates in
this house specifically I think I've
lived with over 25 people in the last
couple years and it's just like it
doesn't feel like my home like even
though I bought it even though I pay the
bills every month even though everything
it's just like feels like the hype house
not my house I've lived in that for
three plus years and I just want like I
want to buy a place I want to set it up
my way the way I would not for Content
not for roommates like my house just
like where every room has a value to
meet like I want to build a gym I want
to build a podcast room will my
girlfriend have an office I want to have
like all these specific things that I
want
in my house like I don't need a 10
bedroom house I need like a three or
four bedroom house like a normal house
and it's just like it doesn't feel like
a home to me so like that's my immediate
priority I'm curious what do you look
for when it comes to tick talkers like
who could be in the high pass like what
qualities I think it's changed over the
years
um but I I can always sense when
someone's about to take off and I don't
know if it's just I'm sure maybe there's
a lot of people out there that are like
that but I I like know early on it's
hard to tell like just why like what
about it you can see the growth the
repetition on your for you page I don't
know the community too yeah you can see
the bond they have with their fans like
I can just tell when things are working
and I've just kind of had that eye out
for it for a while and it helps that
everyone who's coming to Hype house ends
up leaving with a lot more followers
every single time so that helps but it
what I've noticed is there's people who
get views and there's people who have
communities and if you can do both
you'll be very very successful because
that's the best thing you can do is have
a relationship with your audience and
high Palace has a good relationship with
its fan base which is interesting
because it's an entity it's weird but
whenever people come in like our fans
get so excited and it's it's nice to see
like it's cool that they've been so
supportive over the past couple years
because they it's like nobody but me is
in it from the first house like from my
first launch you're the only person I'm
the only person like my girlfriend was
there from the second like from or into
the first house but like towards the end
but nobody else has been in it but
whenever I add five new people and start
posting like the attention goes insane
like the fan base gets excited and the
edits go crazy and it's just like really
cool that even when it's brand new
people it's because kids they're bored
like people out there are bored so when
you give them somebody to pay attention
to they get really excited because it's
just something to focus on sure I think
entertainment is it'll always be there
because people need a distraction from
what's going on in life that's why I've
always tried to just make entertaining
stuff whether it makes people laugh
whether people make fun of it whether it
makes them happy whatever it is it's
like at least we're entertaining to some
level because things get boring really
quick how do you deal with some of the
drama that comes along with it though
that's a good question
um I hate it personally I don't like
drama I don't like bad blood I try my
best to stay neutral with everything and
everybody but there's been times where
it's been public drama and stuff like
that but I I just
I don't like it and I'm also older now
like I feel like drama comes when
there's issues and then they get put
online and you're just like
it's very easy to keep it offline but
obviously like I made mistakes in the
past too and blasted people online it
just didn't give a and stuff like
that but it's like it's just immaturity
like the older you get you're kind of
just like I don't have time for this
like I don't care if it gains me more
followers or whatever it's like I just
don't want to talk about other people I
want to talk about myself and what I'm
doing like I just don't care I'm very
like even if people have wronged me I
hope that they do well like I'm a very
like
I just hope that you find happiness
success and all that stuff like I just
want everyone to learn on their own and
even if they've done bad things to me I
think the life always comes full circle
where it's like you'll figure it out
eventually or like you'll end up
focusing on yourself and things will get
better for you and like that's all I
really care about just I don't have time
for drama and I don't like I don't have
energy for it it's very draining and
what's gonna happen to the hype house
once you sell the high pass and you just
buy a personal residence there's options
for it but my what I'm leaning towards
is adding people from all over the
country that don't live in the same
house so just using it as a place
because I wanna I really respect what
Dave portnoy's done with bar stool and
hype house is such a big name like a lot
of people know the name hype house
whether they hate it or love it whatever
it may be most people hate it but it's
got a lot of attention on it and I want
to use that to blow people up in a
different way like instead of just
gaining followers and doing Tick Tock
Trends and all that like I want to take
people who have a podcast and use it as
a way to blow up their podcast through
high pass through posts and clips on
hype house instead of just their
personals so it's like using it as a
utility for a group of people in that
and that that's what I want to Pivot the
like
um the direction of it that'd be
interesting so kind of like a promotion
type thing kind of but they're all part
of a collective and if we are together
we can film together and stuff like that
so but I just think it's been very
limited by one house for so long and
I've thought about investing into other
houses and do all that but it's just
it's the same it's a net negative
business I'm gonna sell it it seems like
you get a good offer from like somebody
to take over the high pass or is it more
about you I mean if I got a good offer I
probably would but
um everyone has a prize yeah if anyone
wants to buy it yeah
um no I mean I actually have had that
conversation once
um but it mainly came into what if
someone took it over
and then like when because if I sell it
it's not my problem anymore or anything
like that like what if they go sign a
bunch of talent take 25 of what they
make say they're gonna blow them up
through there and then what if they
don't know how what if they don't know
how to actually help them like what if
they just them over and then it's
like even if it's not my problem because
I sold it I'd still feel like right it's
hard to write your name well I helped
with that and then they all these
people over so it's like
I'd rather just try to figure out a way
to do it myself and it's such a big
thing still like even though
it's not the same as it was years ago
and it's not the same like hype level
and all that it's just I want to create
something new the for you page is very
designed to the viewer so it's like if I
took people from anywhere it'll just hit
our fans plus their fans so it just
continues to build their reputation so
that's a tool that could be used for
people but I just want to find more
people that are willing to put in work
to do more than just Tick Tock or more
than just like social media like I want
to find people that want to do bigger
things with their careers overall that's
kind of like where the direction I'm
going is where do you think the
direction is going for a lot of these
tick tockers right now most people just
turn to Snapchat because of that Revenue
I don't know if you guys are on there
but I think most people pivoted away
from Tick Tock right now
um I don't know if Tick Tock is going to
figure their out or if they're not
but it doesn't seem like it's going
great for them but that's just my
personal opinion I love the app and
everything it's done for me and hype
house and all the people and everything
but there's not much opportunity on it
like you can hit people
through clips for you long form I'd say
that's the most useful thing that's
changed over the past couple years but
as just a short form Creator it doesn't
really make sense like the putting all
your energy into it there's not as much
of a return on investment anymore we're
back in the day like you could put a
bunch of work in and it would gain you
on Instagram YouTube all that you don't
really gain off of tick tock anymore
it's like good for people that you guys
to post your Clips on because then it
blows up the podcast it leads to more
Revenue
Etc but for short form creators like
everyone gets millions of views now and
now the brands the my one pet peeve I
have a tick tock is that when you get a
brand deal they completely muted out
like you could be getting a 5 million
view average and then you post a brand
new against 50 000 views yeah why is
that is it because you have to select
paid it's because they want if this is
my guess but I would guess that it's
because Tick Tock wants the brand to pay
for paid advertisements so they can make
money
so because like then you everyone boosts
the videos now like when you get a brand
deal they boost it to millions of people
but that's how Tick Tock makes money if
they don't have that house do they make
money off your brand deals right so it
makes sense in theory but then you start
realizing like you're kind of screwing
over the creators that are that have
helped develop your platform because
without I think that the way that you
make a platform successful is you give
people the opportunity to become famous
like I think that's what happened with
Vine I think that's what happened
musically I think that's what happened
Tick Tock is like
I think hype house and like the people
in it and Charlie and all these people
really helped Tick Tock solidify itself
like I think without those creators
less people would have wanted to be tick
talkers because like they saw all these
people these guys and girls becoming
famous for quote-unquote nothing like
whether it was dances or Trends or
whatever it might be I feel like that
gives people hope in a platform that
they could be that so it's like you you
see people like that blow up and you're
like I if I put work in I could do what
they did but right now there's like none
of that it's more like if I develop a
podcast and post Clips I'll be able to
transfer the views over to YouTube it's
not I'm gonna make so much on Tick Tock
or like I'm gonna build a career off
Tick Tock or I'm going to become famous
off of tick tock so I don't know the pop
the platform's strange right now I feel
like especially when you use your Tick
Tock to leverage other yeah career paths
like like how people become musicians
like we've seen that so much from being
a lot more common yeah I know exactly
are people just becoming mainstream
celebrities like going to red carpets
and stuff like that and hanging out with
the Kardashians and whatnot it's like
okay like yeah really amazing celebrity
at that point but if you view it as like
they started off Tick Tock that's such
an inspiration for so many people out
there it's the same way that I viewed it
Casey neistat when I I started YouTube
at 16 as I was like this guy is just a
dude in New York with a camera like
chasing his dream of being a
videographer and starting a business and
all this it made me feel like I want to
be a YouTuber when I'm older and that
hope was what was there for tick Talkers
in 2019 to 20 20 21 and now I feel like
I don't I just I don't know if I don't
I'm not educated on it but I don't know
if 16 year olds out there now are like I
want to be a tick tocker like I don't
know there's no there's no true money
like intake it's like the promotions and
everything if they're just continually
getting stifled no no company is gonna
allocate a marketing budget towards tick
talkers so then you can't like flaunt
all of your Tick Tock wealth and
therefore you know people wouldn't be
very interested in doing it so it's like
everyone knows YouTube works but
YouTube's now more of uh
I'd save YouTube's more of a
what's the word for like uh science no
no like like Nickelodeon a network oh
YouTube is very much like a network now
you have to have a
overview of what you want to do it's not
very like old YouTube was like set your
camera up and film some funny and
post it new YouTube is like develop a
show idea or develop it's very corporate
very corporate yeah which
works but it also has lost that like I
want to be a YouTuber so I feel like
right now there's like nothing like I
feel like there's no I want to be a
YouTuber a tick tock or Instagram person
like I feel like all the platforms have
become very analytical and become very
soulless I feel like it went from a from
an art like a creative Outlet into a
science or to a business yeah well this
is the thing it's that sucks is like I
love business and I love negotiating
brand deals for myself and I love the
agency side for myself it's really fun I
love growing on social media and
treating the analytics side like a game
and like all that I love that part
but I think the whole
genuineness to social media is supposed
to be just like put your phone up in
film and I think that's why I love when
people like Keith Lee blow up because he
like in my book deserves it because he's
just honest and like puts his phone up
in films something genuine and I'm just
like I want the platforms to go back to
that not like one person who gets that
every two years like a bunch of people
like I feel like it's just kind of like
one person at a time now on Tick Tock
where it used to be everyone but it's
also so oversaturated it's like how many
people can do the same thing and then
how like not everyone can blow up for
the same thing the difference was when
we were on Tick Tock and like it was
actually when it was first blowing up
and all that
if you looked at a trending sound you
would see all of your friends as the top
20. like when I would click in I would
be like oh they did that sound they
did that sound they did that sound all
of my people
or like all of my friends in my network
were under the same sound because I was
just such a small Niche amount of people
on Tick Tock now if a dance goes viral
it's like millions of people doing the
exact same thing so it's like how are
you gonna pick one person to blow up out
of that it doesn't really make sense a
lot of people that start from somewhere
like when you're just a group of friends
hanging out and you blow up everyone
wants to maintain that as they build
their following but in reality you're
not gonna live that same life because
it's impossible you live in an apartment
and you go viral in an apartment filming
with your friends and then you guys make
money and you move into a house it
doesn't make you any less of what you
were doing like that's the whole point
of it so when I bought my first car when
I did all this like I filmed it all and
it wasn't like people viewed it as like
oh you're trying to be cocky or flaunt
or whatever I was like no I'm just
bringing you along the journey and I
bring you along the bad times too and
it's like that's just life like that's
how you create a more special bond
with your audience it's like I'm not the
perfect person at this but you know a
lot of people do that and I feel like
someone like Keithley I don't like
bringing him up a bunch but like he's
great though yeah he is great and and he
does such a good job at he connects with
his audience like when he moved out of
his place he made it a very heartfelt
thing that like that place was where he
started in this and now he can afford to
bring his family to something better but
no one hates on him for that like people
get scared of like posting their success
and I understand because there's a lot
of negatives they're gonna hate on him
when he moves into that 13 bedroom
mansion exactly it's it's got to get to
a point where it's yeah
exactly but at the same time you're just
like you keep it real and you're gonna
have those supporters you'll always have
haters everyone will always have haters
but if you keep it very real with your
fans throughout your time like they'll
connect with you a lot more than other
people and I know a lot of people that
put on a very big facade for social
media and they're just very different
people and it always ends up being
tiring like at some point you're just
like I'm putting on a fake face it's
like that's why when I'm depressed or
have issues like I just don't post on
YouTube like I'm not gonna sit there and
smile and pretend that everything's
great when it's not it's just like I'd
rather take a break yeah because that's
just what I need and like I know that
that's not great for analytics or career
or whatever but that's where you're just
looking it's like I'm not even putting
out good stuff if I'm not feeling good
or if I'm going through something that
sucks like I'm just gonna take a break I
feel like that's uh what David dobrik
did Super well because like he initially
started out in an apartment and then
just slowly like he got the nicer house
and you got like the Mansion but like
his fans are with him the entire way
yeah I think a lot of times people don't
realize how much money you make yeah so
they're like wait a second he's doing
that well
he's making money off me what I think a
lot of people that I think that was one
of the
one of the roughest things though it was
just like really it sucks when you have
to say no to people because like I'm the
type of person where like I take every
photo every human that has asked me in
public take a photo with Beyond grateful
that they even know who I am but at the
second house when like I'm pulling my
car out and I have to go to a meeting
and like there's nine people knocking on
my windows and then the moms are like we
made you I'm like you're at my
house you psychopath like you're at my
house you crazy of a mom take your
kid away from my house are you like you
have to be delusional to bring someone
to someone's private residence and wait
outside for eight hours they wait
outside for eight hours every second if
we would leave at five in the morning
there'd be people there and it was just
like the fact that they were sitting out
there like you wouldn't have any of
these without us and I'm like I didn't
say that they would say that oh yeah the
moms were crazy but it's just like who
are you to like show up to someone's
house and like we tried to take photos
but then it became uh right then it's
expected no no you just oh you go to the
house and they take photos with you yep
not only that the police were upset with
us because the road got shut down from
so many cars it's like there's so many
issues that came up from that that we
weren't allowed to take pictures anymore
and then once we told people that they
were like yeah you're full of and I
was like no we literally like are we are
going to get evicted because of this so
it was just like it was just getting
worse and worse but people just they
feel
as someone uh told me this recently who
it was like a manager friend of mine
that worked with celebrities and
influencers and he was saying it's very
interesting to see the difference
between how people treat influencers in
public versus celebrities like he was
just like oh I I you know I'll be out at
dinner with blank major celebrity like
major comedian he'd be like people might
recognize them but they have the respect
to like stay away from him whereas like
when I'm out with my influencer clients
like anyone feels like it's free game at
a restaurant to come up be like hey
selfie real quick it's like you know the
person yeah it's like you're it's not
like oh that's that actor where you get
very reserved and you're like oh that's
that famous actor like if you someone
saw Tom Holland at a cafe they're like
oh my God that's Spider-Man they like
freak out and then that's it where when
they see an influencer they're like oh
my God it's this person from I'm gonna
go take a picture with them but it's
like
the respect part goes out the window
which I get just influencers I get that
whole perspective but it's like that
also gets irritating when you're like
out and that's just the way people just
expect it and then when they get to the
point where like they're at your house
and then they're demanding it and you're
just like just give me a little space
like maybe don't come to my house maybe
please that's crazy that you actually
got nearly evicted yeah we had many many
break-ins per house that's supposed to
be your one space and like they would
try to come in the garage when it was
shutting they would try to get higher
security though I think we did it once
yeah
um
yeah we had security at one point that
was that house was crazy you're really
good at storytelling yeah I think you'd
rate talk really good in a podcast
that's why like especially now I'm like
doubly excited for you to start one
really I've always wanted to I think
it's just that too like everyone who
goes the podcast route and then they go
the like all especially Tech talkers and
YouTubers that they always go like the
drama out I don't want that like I want
to talk to intellectual people and I
want to I want to learn something when
I'm talking so you want to have guests
on every episode guest on every episode
I want I don't care if they're famous or
not or as long as they have something to
bring to the conversation yeah like I
love Joe Rogan's podcast I love Jordan
Peterson's next podcast I don't watch
Lexus but I should wow yeah I I love Lex
Friedman they're they're just all like I
like when people bring other people on
and they learn new things and you're
running a good podcast you have to be
like humble enough to listen to New
Perspectives and all of a sudden it's
just like I want to do that and I want
to feel like I'm growing all the time as
a person and I want to be surrounded by
people doing better than me and that's
that's something really important I feel
like a lot of people don't understand
you are who you're surrounded by and I
think that's probably the biggest like
if there's anyone out there watching
that's like hey what's the advice that I
could give to make money I'd say forget
all the analytical things for a second
who are you surrounded by because if
you're around a bunch of broke people
that don't work and that get high all
day and watch movies you're not going
anywhere it's just like it's not going
to happen the more you're around other
people who have that same mindset you
guys will figure it out together like I
that I think that's the most important
thing is your surroundings couldn't
agree more to that I had a close old
friend that I haven't really been
hanging out with recently called me and
she was like really struggling like in
shambles and everything and she was like
what do I do like do you have some
advice and I was like yeah like just
stop being friends with every single
person you're friends with right now and
go find like a new friend group that is
in the direction you want to go in life
yeah I know it's sounds so it's
aggressive it's abrupt it sounds
up but it's also like
you need good people around you to
elevate yourself and it's like if you're
not making a lot of money go make some
friends that are making more money and
they will teach you or you will learn
how they're doing it or you'll see their
mannerisms that change and all this
stuff it's like you can't just expect to
grow sitting in the same spot so that
yeah that's that would be a big piece of
advice for you and it sounds I've cut
off so many bad people in my life that
I'm just like if I'm around you and I
don't feel like
were benefiting off each other
emotionally
um career-wide whatever it may be if
there is no like wow we're not building
each other up there's no point being in
each other's lives and like I've had to
deal with family and a lot of people are
incapable of doing that which I
understand but it's also just like you
gotta you only live so long you gotta
live a good life and a happy life and be
surrounded by people you enjoy their
company and all that stuff so that's
very important to me what's your biggest
insecurity by eczema probably really
yeah I hate it I'm not gonna be one to
downplay it other people's insecurities
that's not gonna be me but I also think
yeah there could be a better one um no
no I don't think that that's I'm not
gonna be a better security yeah that's
that yeah I've like because you can see
it on my hands I don't really care about
my hands but as a kid oh like insides of
my legs arms I always wore sweaters and
jeans and everything every day even if
it was 100 degrees out no shorts that's
raw yeah it's just embarrassing
oh yeah it's terrible I wouldn't wish
eggs so how do you how do you fix it
there is no fix it's just a lifelong
thing there's not a pill there's not
like a steroids yeah but you don't want
to take stuff like my dad my dad has
eczema too really bad and like he's done
everything steroid shots
um steroid ointments everything and he
still has it at in his 60s
and or late 50s but he still has it not
as bad as me but like pretty close for
doing everything right and like all the
medical things right it's like it still
comes back
still so you're still gonna have to deal
with it at some point so I'd rather just
take the more like holistic route and
that might sound dumb but like sure he's
had cataracts twice because of the
steroids it's like they they thin
everything so it's like if you put if
you put um like steroid creams on this
it'll just thin the skin out it'll heal
it but it'll thin the skin out and then
you get that paper thin skin you like
old people have like all the all the
veins through that's what happens so I'm
just like I'd rather just find a natural
way or just live with it but it does
suck what do you think is the biggest
problem with Humanity or the biggest
threat to humanity
I don't know I'm not educated enough to
say threat
um but I don't like the current mindset
of America as far as I don't like how
divisive everyone is and I don't like
how everything's set in stone like if
you have one opinion you're evil or if
you have a another opinion you're a
saint it's just like
I don't know I don't like the way that
everything is so if you think this you
are this and if you think this you're
this it's just like there's kind of no
open conversation anymore and I don't
like the way that that is right now and
the media is very divisive and all this
stuff it's just like I I don't like it I
feel like everyone's on social media
right now though is it pushes yeah on
both ends yeah and then you like see you
could fall into a loophole of just being
fed propaganda on I on both sides of
political everything like religious what
like you can just like fall into a
rabbit hole and it just keeps feeding
you because like all these platforms are
good at feeding you what you want so if
you want to see something extreme you're
going to keep seeing something extreme
so people engage with as well yeah
exactly but it makes sense from uh
algorithm perspective but then you're
like what are you doing to these people
though like think about it from a human
perspective I agree I think like there's
really bad intolerance yeah everybody of
the other side with regards to
everything then it goes with everything
it's like there's these kids out there
who watch all day that get on the work
side of tick tock that's like the grind
harder work harder do this and it's like
I agree I agree with all those things I
promote those things but also like
sitting there listening to motivational
edits all day you need to work harder if
you don't know what you're doing
there's nothing you could like it just
gets that those kids end up in the same
spot with like I watch this all day and
I want to work all day but I haven't
even taken a step in the right direction
because I'm so busy being like I gotta
work 12 hours a day or I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna make it yeah it's like what's
making it mean like what it what do you
really want do you want money is that
the end-all be-all goal because you're
not gonna build most likely just off of
financial like I want to be a
millionaire it's like everyone does
what do you want to do what impact do
you want to make what career do you want
to have what what is the thing but like
people are so focused on the finance
like I want to make money or I want to
do that so I want to buy a house it's
like why like I know why I want to buy a
house I didn't have a stable house
Growing Up So owning my own home was a
big step for me because I was like this
is mine I have no one can I can't leave
no one can kick me out no one can do
this like that's why I want a stable
home so I bought it it's like that was
my intention when I started hype house
there was no I'm gonna get rich I'm
gonna do this it was just genuine and
then it led to an opportunity to make
money through growing on social media
and all that but if you so focus on like
oh I got to make money doing this are
you gonna do it if you're so focused on
like I want to meet the perfect
girlfriend or perfect boyfriend is that
gonna happen if that's all you think
about no it's gonna happen when you
least expect it so it's just like I
agree I think like real wealth isn't
something you really pursue but it's
something more that ensues like it just
kind of comes as a byproduct to
something else well and you notice like
all these I don't know how true this is
but you notice a lot of these people
like Elon Musk is unbelievably
successful it's like he kind of gambled
everything back on another business once
he made money multiple times like that's
Insanity from any logical person's
perspective but he's clearly passionate
about what he does it's like didn't he
pull out so much money to buy Twitter
it's like was that a logical decision or
was that just what he felt was the right
thing to do for him that seemed
impulsive to me that's what I'm saying
so it's like that's to seem like on a
whim it's like I'm gonna do it I doubt
he did that impulsively I bet it was
very calculated but I also obviously it
wasn't the smart business decision we
tried to get out of it yeah I know yeah
yeah and they didn't want to sell it to
him initially which was a funny thing
and he's like no please let me buy it
and then he starts getting in contracts
like I want to back out no you can't now
I just I think as soon as they say yes
he's like well actually yeah if they
kept saying no he'd be like no I still
won yeah yeah yeah yeah I think that but
I I just look at people like that and
I'm like he's someone I look up to
entrepreneur wise and I'm just like well
if he's willing to gamble at all like
you kind of got to do that sometimes and
I tell everyone this too when you're
young you don't really have anything to
lose it's like that was my thought when
I started hype house in 20 20 or 2019
I don't know how much money I had in my
bank account maybe like 20 grand but I
spent every dollar yeah but I was like
what am I gonna lose like oh I'm gonna
be 21 with 20 grand or maybe 21 with a
thousand dollars it's the same like
you're not really going to change your
life with 20 grand like maybe if you're
really smart you could buy a chain with
that yeah
it's like you kind of got to go all in
on yourself and believe in yourself and
maybe it'll work if you believe hard
enough you might get a chance of success
but it's like look you got on here
through trying something right seven
emails in a row but it's like it works
but if you didn't try
true it's just like you got to try
something gotta go all in on something
and maybe it'll work for you all right
that's fantastic thank you so much for
coming on thank you for being generous
with your time I really appreciate it if
there's anything you want to shout out
go ahead this podcast there we go
subscribe hit the like button all of
your stuff will be left down below in
the description and until next time see
you guys cool thank you so much